the one record that i heard from you
that really kind of like grabbed me was
the heaven and hennessy record which i
felt like was like a super dope
vulnerable record
um
is it your biggest record on spotify i
want to say so yeah um
that record uh
we don't get a lot of like
artists really kind of channeling what
it like what those emotions are on songs
where you really feel them i guess like
where were you what what place were you
at in life when you when you wrote that
and recorded it a frustrated place
trying to figure life out where i'm
going where i'm heading where i was you
know and just being stuck in between
like a rock and a hard place not only
in
like my community but like
in my career right you know like
when am i gonna get this
like everything that i've been like
being i feel like i've been working
towards and it's just like damn when am
i gonna get this break like this big
break that us this artist always
imagined that we're gonna have and this
is that in the third and it was just
kind of like for me
i'm like okay i need to bear it all and
i need to explain where i'm at and how i
feel because i know there are other
people out there
whether you're whatever it is or
whatever industry that you work in you
know that feel like how i feel
you know so it's just really just
getting that on record you know and um
um
man
everybody tells me all the time like man
having a hennessy that's one of my
favorite records i just did a pop-up and
somebody hit me they were like yo
can you guys play heaven and hennessy
i'm pulling up make sure y'all play
every hennessy that's one of my favorite
records so